you're kidding or not I don't know
either and don't be a Grinch news
submitted by it's the most wonderful
time of the year a study revealed that
early Christmas decorating is good for
you let's plug for my sketch you should
check it out it's all about decorating
too early hey guys Nikki limo what's too
early it was on Halloween Day in the
sketch I like that though I agree with
that I was at [ __ ] Costco the day of
Halloween and they already had a
Christmas aisle yeah it's crazy
it's that big five in August and there's
[ __ ] pumpkins and [ __ ] yeah in
Michael's to know is like summertime and
there was like Christmas decoration how
do you think Thanksgiving feels bad
whose Thanksgiving we also did a sketch
about that as call this Christmas and
things came oh my god that's a good plug
thank you thank you
Nikki lame-o you just check out the
sketch please I just want to talk about
Christmas are you a big Christmas man
Steve okay so here's the thing I was
always against like against decorating
early very against very strongly now
that I have a family and I have like we
have like a place and we could decorate
it I [ __ ] love it I think it's great
and I want to do it earlier and earlier
Christmas was such a joke are you so
angry
about how much you love Christmas though
I used to be very different used to be
very very opposed against I was against
if you will be where like we actually
think that just logs about it on my
watch it's youtube.com slash Nikhil a
movie for you the blogs water blog
channel youtube.com slash Nikki yeah
which might start back up again it might
turn into a family vlog channel you know
we were just talking about because for
the sketch that we did it was about
people that decorate too early and we
put we had to put the Christmas
decorations up for the sketch and then
people were like so you guys I have it
up already and I was like no we took
them down because my birthday is
November 2nd and I kind of get I kind of
get weird if it's like before my
birthday I know that's a weird thing is
like it's been about me it's my birthday
but it's not about that it's just like
you know childhood nostalgia it's like
it comes after my birthday so if things
go to order
really makes you up yeah books me yeah
yeah yeah it's like that sleep rhythm
that bio Katie yeah can you live them
chickadee and that's at Arcadia
educators it's all messed up I feel like
and for us it's like well I'm gone half
of December you know go leaving the
state delayed go visit family i North
Carolina and Michigan and so I'm like I
need to start decorating in you know
July so that I get the full experience
of it I said what I did was like I got
ACL surgery over Thanksgiving a couple
years ago and so I should first time I
convinced my husband I was like all I
really want is to have Christmas
decorations up while I'm sitting on the
couch with my torn ACL and he was like
okay we can put him up early and then
ever since we put him up early that's
cute
when do you do it um it's getting
earlier and earlier like I want to do it
this Saturday I went to Target on Monday
and they didn't have their [ __ ] ready
what
Targhee the boxes were out they were
they online you should write a letter
you should complain and has the slip is
sold out on my fault the [ __ ] yeah
people really it's November 7th in case
you're wondering what HIA is do we got a
[ __ ] nine-foot tree I just wanted to
give that upload to the tip 3 joke right
cool is it a real one or a fake one's a
fake one tree 9 foot you're crazy
yeah we finally have toss hoes your
ceiling
it's like mine
yeah yeah all right so goes to the
second floor that's where the start is
that's what rich people do yeah yeah I
heard yeah we're [ __ ] loaded so yeah
nine four tree all right so they're
saying here that when you put up
decorations you're thinking of happier
times times with family and friends and
family traditions that you've engaged in
especially during your childhood so if
you are a person who ends up putting
their decorations up a lot earlier then
it really it triggers your Pleasant
childhood memories and not only that but
you're giving the impression to your
neighbors and everyone that comes across
your home that you're a basic [ __ ] know
that you're a good person like a
friendly person like someone who's
actually engaged in like their holidays
and stuff and like they're they're
actually wanting to embrace the the
festive spirit and not just for
Christmas like for all the other
holidays too like for Halloween like
once you like think about if you drive
by a house that's all decorated for
Halloween and stuff you're like oh
that's tight they're into it like you
immediately already assume the type of
person that's living in that home
sometimes it's kind of overboard we just
drove by this one house yeah this guy he
look like they murder people this guy
look this front guard probably had a
good 300 mummies are life-size like
zombies and some of them are grabbing
their hair the other one and cutting it
all right God yeah it's a graphics
really grass and I'm like who's that for
I don't know it's like if I was a kid
house no tripping no let's get the real
body
this person was a psychopath he's like
it's Monday yeah I don't know if this
guy's like great way to hide body spirit
but plain sight that's a good point like
with depending on the type of
decorations that you have you can really
see a person cuz having to have gone by
those homes weren't like for Christmas
when there's you can't even see their
[ __ ] home that it's like completely
covered in Christmas decorations are
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with this
but if it looks tight there that's good
but some people I think think it looks
tight but it doesn't look like if they
have a bush and it's all [ __ ] hanging
off yes yes that [ __ ] with it looks like
they just took
like to just shucked another thing and
they're like yeah I think we're good or
you see have you seen a giant [ __ ]
inflatable Christmas dragon thing it's
absurd you can't see very well it's a
sin no [ __ ] dragon and it's got like
a little Santa hat on and that makes it
Christmas but it looks trash when you
see you're like this is white trash [ __ ]
I've even seen Christmas law what oh
yeah yeah why can't we just stick to the
traditional animals like now we're
bringing in all these other weird yeah
I've got that inflatable thing equal
equal animal kingdom Christmas have you
seen that a playable thing where it's
got like snow and I am but it looks
trash it looks trans because in
California it's still hot so it just
gets all foggy in there alright like
mana lawn made of just sand yeah is it
trash if you know people pets sometimes
to put like lisanna make it look like
reindeer that's cute for my cat when I
was a Christmas tree the other ones a
Santa Claus but they never let me win so
I put the Santa Claus one on my cat
every year and he [ __ ] hates it cuz
cats do not like being dressed up at all
but once it's on he feels like he can't
move yeah he's a saint the best we move
backwards the Train yeah that's pretty
funny the best day is because he's
wearing it it's good it's like a beard
with the but the best part about it is
that he initially fights it and then his
spirit breaks it's just like usually a
tick-tock that kind of stuff kills oh
yeah oh [ __ ]
I have no idea how to use that you have
to teach me try I'm just one with the
youths
yeah the youth you know okay but how
about those people that put up Christmas
decorations on Halloween like taking
over other holidays I think those are
mean-spirited people that is
you've seen someone put up Christmas
stuff yes there's a guy on our street
who did it yes it's pretty weird that
early and so trick-or-treaters are
coming up and there are low costumes and
it's like jingle bells over there and he
did nut job I was like brother did you
do this [ __ ] like nine days ago he's up
all night it's like it was almost like I
got show um you guys already set up your
house for Christmas and then took it
down do you feel like you're gonna be
burnt out no I did you take it down
because my birthday Halloween week like
before Halloween because it was during
the sketch and then my birthday is two
days after Halloween so like you were
saying how it reminds you of childhood
put up Christmas decorations to do it
before my birthday or like before
Halloween it like [ __ ] up my childhood
memories you feel like you're gonna be
your circadian yeah it's gonna be all
messed up because you already like kind
of celebrated Christmas a little bit and
then you like took it down I could pass
off as a good January in here we have a
tradition that we make mulled wine and
put up Christmas decorations while we
play like yeah we play The Grinch yeah
but if you play the Grinch it's 30
minutes long you got to like play it on
the plane a lot for quite other
directors cut Jim Carrey yeah you know
that one's so bad though mannequin it's
so how do have you actually took the
watch tonight's work yeah or not lately
but I like cuz I was a kid too listen
he's good in it but the movies very
overly long and the pacing is terrible
what's the Gretsch that's only 30
minutes the real original is that the
one where they have this all this trench
yeah I think it structural yeah
Chuck Jones yeah the guy who did he did
all the Looney Tunes animations oh we
also we put up the tree it's already pre
decorated with the lights and then we
didn't put ornaments on it so it was
just the lights it just looks really
like decorated because the way they have
it preset it looks decorated oh no we
don't have that training where we've
done it it's a JK because our cats just
see it as one gigantic scratch post so
I'm like [ __ ] we could never have a
Christmas tree you guys got a [ __ ]
yard you gotta fill that a [ __ ] up man
cuz I was so jealous
tear it bro no I know but I was so
jealous I was at Costco I saw this
gigantic 101 tour
our snowman that wasn't as track I can't
[ __ ] put this anywhere where am I
gonna put it
you're pretty on your patio picked up
the whole [ __ ] thing next to your
knives with tree we should just turn
your dirt into an ice-skating rink
oh it's all blank right now get like
white spray paint and just spray paint
the entire floor yeah that's tight no I
know you're joking but they really do
have snow great babe
really yeah it's like frosty I thought
it'd be honest here the game of Thrones
there was a guy with like a sack he's
like I'm in the fakes neither one you
get it really good spray I don't know
what makes it different from white spray
paint it just says maybe it's got
texture yeah it has texture and and it's
different it's where people put on your
windows make it windows it frost oh that
ought to know yeah okay got you I'm not
crazy
no it sounds more it's really ball 2
versus spray paint that might be more
permanent know how good that is for the
environment just spraying it under the
ground it's Christmas I think it's okay
yeah it's totally fine
those are the rules we did that
Halloween video in the middle of October
and I had to put on 15 different
Halloween costumes and at the end of it
I was like I'm done with Halloween yeah
I was done I didn't even dress up the
weekend before I was just like I did
Halloween three weeks ago I'm over it
that makes sense too much Halloween yeah
there isn't that's true that's too I
could mainline Christmas into my [ __ ]
arm did I also like that it's like okay
to get all like glittery and dressed up
like you know you get invited to a
normal party if you show up in glitter
you're an [ __ ] but if you show up to
a Christmas party like sequins and like
baubles and stuff it's like oh you're
festive that's true it's the only time
you get someone do that
I like secretly hate ugly Christmas
sweaters yeah I just want to dress up
yeah yeah you only get sold so many
months to do that so many weeks at least
we don't have poverty
[Music]